Loki season 2 episode 4 left a lot of
fans speechless all of the theories
about Victor timley going on to become
good or bad or he who remains out the
window because spoiler alert if you
haven't seen it he
do and apparently everybody else is
about to die as well or are they of
course we're only on episode 4 and there
are two episodes left it's very clear
that Loki is not just going to die in
this episode but how exactly is everyone
going to survive and what happens next
well there are many things that have
been leading up to this moment in
episode 4 and I still believe the theory
that there is a he who remains variant
out there who is kind of controlling
everything still and I think he still
could be doing that alongside of OB and
that might sound weird considering the
fact that it looks like OB is about to
die but what if this was all a part of
he who remains his plan and I actually
think that there was some lying going on
by OB in this episode but I do also
believe that Loki and Sylvie are going
to save everybody in the next episode
but is that a part of he who remains his
plan insiders have hinted that he who
remains is going to be returning and
we'll explain in this video how that
could make sense how he could be behind
everything still but how Loki and Sylvie
are also going to manage to save
everybody so let's break down the ending
and what could possibly happen but first
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest Loki breakdowns and of
course MCU news and we're doing a
giveaway right now if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered for a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner picks one
item and we pick one winner at the end
of each month so Loki season 2 episode 4
included a lot in it and as we did last
week we'll be breaking down this episode
over the course of a few different
videos now as far as how Loki and Sylvie
are possibly going to save everybody
there are some major points to this
episode that you have to know as you saw
Rana Rin Slayer and Miss minutes have
returned to the TV VA and when they got
there they murdered a lot of people in a
very cruel way but besides that when
they got back Miss minutes began taking
the TVA basically offline for anybody
but herself and RN Slayer none of the
tin pads worked for anyone not for OB
not for Mobius not for Loki and Miss
minut started to sabotage Loki and
Sylvie when they got in the elevator she
shut the door before Loki could get in
when Sylvie was in the elevator she shut
it down Miss minutes was basically
getting in the way so OB said that he
could reboot the system which would take
her offline but he said that there was a
problem with that because it would reset
all of the safety features of the TVA
basically the procedures that were in
place and the powers that the TVA had to
prevent magic use in the TVA would be
off line but Mobius and Loki and Sylvie
of course say to do it because one not
only will it take Miss minutes offline
and she won't interfere anymore but then
Loki and Sylvie can use their powers
this is one of the big ways that Loki
and and Sylvie are going to be able to
save everybody they are going to be able
to use their powers another major thing
that you need to know is that time
travel is now possible within the TVA
whereas this was not possible before
this was a major theme of the very first
episode Time slipping time glitching
time traveling whatever should not be
possible in the TVA time does not
operate the same in the TVA because the
TVA is supposed to exist outside of
SpaceTime however somehow it was
different for Loki and as we saw in the
first episode and this episode Loki had
been going in and out through time the
past the present and the future now this
episode gave us the answer of who pruned
Loki and it was Loki himself in episode
one Loki slipped into the future where
he saw the TVA in shambles and he saw a
future version of Sylvie he was then
pruned this future that he was in is the
current present that Loki and Sylvie are
in in episode 4 Loki hears the phone
ringing he has the prune stick in his
hand and he instantly realizes what is
about to happen as Loki pops up in front
of him and Sylvie begins to get out of
the elevator he realizes that it was
actually himself who pruned him to save
him in his now past so he goes up to his
past self who is actually in his present
right now but is the future for his past
self and he prunes him that can be a
little complicated but basically Loki
saved himself and time travel is
possible in the TVA those are the two
main points you need to know another
extremely huge point that you have to
know is that Sylvie has the temp pad of
he who remains and this is not a normal
temp pad now they haven't exactly told
us how time travel was possible for Loki
in the TVA how he was time slipping that
hasn't exactly been answered yet however
at one point in time Loki did say that
Sylvie opened the portal using he who
remains his temptin Pad perhaps that is
how and I believe this to be true I
believe since he who remains built the
TVA and can control time that time does
exist for him in the TVA and since it
was his Time Pad that's how Loki was
able to go to the past to the present
and to the Future well Sylvie still has
that temp pad So in theory time travel
should still be possible for all of them
not just Sylvie and Loki but Sylvie
should be again in theory able to open
up a portal to go back in time in the
TVA and this is exactly what is going to
happen and we know that because of
trailers that we seen that have footage
of what has not happened yet and what we
are specifically talking about is
footage of Loki going to OB asking what
could we have done differently there are
also two other scenes that lead us to
believe that Loki is going to
continuously go back in time and try and
fix the time Loom and one of the
promotions for Loki season 2 it starts
off by showing us Loki in the time Loom
room saying what I'm about to tell you
is going to be hard to believe again he
specifically says again what I'm about
to tell you it's going to be hard to
believe again that tells us that he has
already done this this is him redoing
what had happened and as you can see in
the background it looks like the time
Loom is on the brink of Destruction or
is about to be destroyed also at the end
of this promo spot we see a scene where
all of them are still together Loki has
a microphone in his hand and he says
again but it also shows us him himself
with no gear on whatsoever walking out
to the time Loom this basically shows us
that Loki is going to be able to repeat
these events over and over and over
again until they can finally get it
right and the time Loom doesn't get
destroyed it doesn't explode and the TVA
doesn't die and everybody inside of it
doesn't die with it so there are really
two options here one which I believe is
probably going to happen is that Loki
and Sylvie and whoever or else using the
tin pad of he who remains keeps going
back in time essentially trying new
things each time trying different things
to make sure the time Loom doesn't
explode and Victor timely doesn't get
spaghettified and I think this is quite
obvious giving what they've shown Us in
the trailers and the promos that we
haven't seen on screen yet of course
another option could be that a future
version of Loki does appear to them in
that moment where everything's about to
be destroyed and tells them what to do
and it actually could be a combination
of both a Loki could appear from the
future and tell them you need to go back
in time using he who remains his temp
pad and try something else keep trying
until it works you'll eventually get it
because we know how time travel stories
work most of the time you typically
can't just tell people what to do you
can't tell people what happens because
as he who remains stated in the finale
of Loki season 1 you know you can't get
to the end without going through the
Journey being changed by the journey
being changed by the process he can't
just tell you how it ends and we have
been seen in season 2 how what he who
remains has said a lot of it is coming
to fruition which leads us to the next
part is this still a part of he who
remains his plan I believe it still
could be we'll dive into that in our
next video but basically he still could
be working with ob because there is a
lot that doesn't exactly make sense in
episode 4 we know he who remains created
the TVA and we know that Victor timley
did not but in this episode OB states
that he learned everything he knew from
Victor timley which does not check out
that does not line up with the past of
the TVA with he who remains creating the
TVA and then wiping everybody's memory
so be on the lookout for our next video
in Loki season 2 episode 4 breakdown and
in the meantime let us know what you
thought about episode 4 and what you
think is going to happen leave all your
thoughts and theories in the comments
down below please don't forget to like
the video and subscribe to stay up to
date on Loki and the MCU you can always
find us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof